so the myth is can a surgical laser
light a fart on fire and ago full-scale
Rachel Valerie and Jesse are recreating
an all too accurate operating room
scenario we are going full-scale and
that's what's happening behind me our
patient has had his chest cut out on top
of that is a screen and on top of the
screen is a bunch of meat because you
know operations include a lot of meat in
the form of humans we are going to pipe
our fart in underneath that meat so it
aerates up through I'm going to dress
all around it with a whole bunch of
surgical towels the most vigorous fuel
we were able to test in scale
hopefully this whole place will be on
fire in a few minutes so the team scrub
up and masterbuilder Jesse plums in the
patient to release gas from the
intestinal area simulating an accidental
colon puncture and premature ejection of
flatus now Buster's just like Adam full
of farts but unlike Adam there's no risk
of Buster failing to perform when the
pressures on yeah you got one I think no
nothing
and in addition to the controlled inflow
of backflow the team is adding one
further ingredient to the mix oxygen
every operating room is an oxygen-rich
environment so we're gonna add oxygen in
the mix and see if we get a better
result
Buster's mask will be leaking oxygen
realistically enriching the soon-to-be
combustible environment and with the
experimental platform matching the
mythical setup as accurately as possible
it's go time
all right this is catastrophic operating
room farts okay I'm going to lower in
the laser
[Music]
okay ladies are starting up in three two
one
we got fire almost immediately okay turn
on the gas count it in letting it rip in
three two one the thermal camera will
reveal if the addition of the oxygen
caused an explosion this is the thermal
oh that was big that was dirty and do it
right did you see that it's fire
engulfed the entire patients chest there
for a second I mean really if that
happened you'd run for your life I mean
I would call that explosion but is it
enough to confirm the myth this one's up
for debate
how do we want to call this personally I
think it's confirmed no way I totally
disagree this is busted we never got our
laser to ignite or far we always had to
introduce a new heat source that's a
good point but our setup is totally
realistic I mean we have the medical
grade laser atoms synthetic fart and the
oxygen in the air around it and I
totally saw a fire and we got a kaboom
okay given that we didn't have to travel
outside the confines of an operating
room to achieve this I'm willing to call
it plausible how do you feel
Paz what is plausible plausible all
right let's get this guy to the or
[Music]
these kind of stories are tricky ones
where the premise is sensational but the
execution requires this perfect storm of
all these disparate elements to come
together to create the catastrophe they
are always butt kickers and this one is
no exception the guys had to go down all
sorts of wrong turns to get to the final
result but they did and my final
takeaway from this is that my parts are
still potent